[Music]  China got into a big fight in a new  preview for Sunday's Keeping Up with the  Kardashians Rob Kardashian and blac  Chyna's relationship unravels and Rob  sisters Kim Kourtney and Khloe are  clearly worried she texts all your  sisters and said that she's ready to  leave you though the 30 year old reality  star says in the clip that he wants his  relationship with the 28 year old model  to work definitely love her and want to  be with her be on again off again couple  welcomed their first child together  daughter dream Kardashian in November  2016 and their tumultuous relationship  was captured on both Robin China and  keeping up Robin China called it quits  earlier this year but continued to spark  reconciliation rumors as they often post  sweet snaps of one another to social  media  [Music]